well Christmas can be hard work and for
more than anyone else for father
Christmas and now scientists have come
up with some theories about how he
manages the deliver presence the
children across the world in just one
night and with me to assess some of the
science of Santa
he's dr. Martin Archer who's a physicist
at Queen Mary University London welcome
to you indeed now first of all let's
just look at the scale of the task it's
reckoned he's got to make 366 million
visits and that involves traveling seven
and a half kilometers which is the
equivalent of ten times to the moon and
back now there are over two billion
children how do we get down to that
figure of 366 so if you take an average
of two children per household and the
thing that really manages to cut it down
is the father Christmas or Santa is very
much tied to Christianity and cultures
that sort of follow that
so if we say Santa only has to go to to
those sorts of places that can
drastically cut it down and I think the
researchers actually took a few people
off because they're on the naughty list
as well oh dear I hope not well let's
just look at the the speed that he has
to go and that's the figure divided the
distance by the 48 hours he's got to do
this in and that calculates we
calculated at two nights because of the
Orthodox calendar which has Christmas in
January at Epiphany that gives Santa two
days to do it in and that reveals that
he needs to move at over a hundred and
fifty thousand kilometres an hour so he
has two days but he's got the full 24
hours both times a week only operates at
night doesn't he he is so if you take
the assumption that a night is roughly
twelve hours to play with but if he does
a trick if he starts out saying around
New Zealand and then takes advantage of
the time zones traveling west through
Europe and then to the States
that gives him in one night technically
whilst it's all dark a full 24 hours per
night all right now just how fast as he
got of work let's have a look at this
this here Mac one that is a speed of
sound so that's when we hear sonic booms
and then America's fastest jet
the u.s. fighter jet that goes at just
over Mach 5 I think it's Mac is it Mac
on that yeah okay but by most
calculations to do all the work for him
Santa's sleigh have a look at this has
got to go Mac 100 and there is a there
there is a problem with this which is
your average reindeer operates at 15
miles per hour which isn't yeah on
ground obviously that and it gets it
even more difficult we have got an
explanation for this but in fact a
reindeer the heat caused by traveling at
the speed of Maca Honda would actually
vaporize the poor reindeer Paul Rudolph
even if the sleigh had a magnetic field
protecting it the sonic boom cause would
also wake all the children up so this is
that this is the big how does Rudolph do
it
never fear there is a solution Santa
probably uses various aspects of quantum
physics and quantum mechanics in
particular there's a theory that says
unless you see a single Santa we can't
know that there aren't multiple centers
operating everywhere there we are
so lots of Santa's the same person in
different places now explain this
quantum physics well yes the quantum
physics is is the world of the atomic
and the subatomic very very small things
and acts in a very peculiar way to our
everyday sort of understanding but it
does seem to be how the world is work
then this idea that you can be in
several places well I mean you have the
idea that particles say like atoms we
think of them as very much like a
snooker ball as as being in a place but
we do see that they can they can be in
multiple places at once and Emmitt's and
decide to switch and it's only when we
actually observe them that it makes a
decision so as long as we don't see
Santa which is the whole point which is
the whole point then kids across the
world can get their presents right so
they don't see Santa kissing I was I saw
Mommy Kissing Santa Claus just don't
have a look it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't at all so in the end the truth
is science makes it
it seems that way but obviously we don't
know for sure because we haven't seen
Santa okay thank you very much indeed
dr. Raj